hmm it's on my babies mm-hmm
I'm excited because today I get to today
I get to go to visit my buddy who's
lived in Venice I had no idea but I
haven't seen him in since I went to NYU
for [ __ ] nine months and I was
friends with him and I am friends with
him we kept in touch you know there's
been a few years that we haven't talked
about and he's my buddy and he was in
the business school of Tish in NYU and I
get to go see him for the first time in
18 years and I get to go do that and I'm
really excited to it because I really
want to see him and it's this [ __ ] and
there were four of us you know and why
you there was me Tom Ted and Dan and
those are the whitest names of all time
and we all hung out and if it was now I
guarantee if it was now that we hung out
the four of us I'll tell you right now
we would be [ __ ] listening to and
I'll getting our teeth done at the
dentist's office but we are chillin and
I haven't talked to Ted in a while I'm
sorry I haven't talked to Tom in a while
Ted I'm gonna go see in a little bit but
I'm very excited because I want to catch
up with him dude we used to left so hard
man they came to visit me in spring
break once and Ted [ __ ] threw up so
hard because he got so drunk cuz we went
to the House of Blues I don't even know
who the [ __ ] we want to go say but we
want to go to the House of Blues and he
started drinking way too much he drank
like something like fire like what do
they call him like mind erasers is what
the [ __ ] you know and then we've we
drove home and he threw the [ __ ] up out
the side of the car and I got so mad
dude it's so a guy named Ted to throw up
at the side of a car and we were all man
tom was laughing and Dan was laughing
and Dan you should laugh like this and
Dan was let me tell you this first so it
becomes less sad later he [ __ ] died
it when I was 27 minus 20 was 27 Marvin
70 was image twice 6 I don't know he got
a [ __ ] he got a motorcycle accident
do it and I [ __ ] loved him and he was
so funny he provided us with so much
[ __ ] laugh
dude goddamn he were provided us with so
many laughs cuz he basically he was the
kind of guy that just lived like he
wanted Goodfellas to be real he wanted
Goodfellas to be real life
Goodfellas in real life is how he wanted
it to be and he he wanted it to be and
this was the craziest thing too he was
we he was Irish
he was like Robert De Niro's character
he was Irish and he wanted to be Italian
so bad he would just be like he was the
kind of guy that like no you know I
don't like the way he [ __ ] looked at
me you know what he's off he's on my
list one time he came out to me he said
hey your buddy Frank he's a carrier huh
and I said what he's a carrier I said
what the [ __ ] does he mean and Ted is
like Ted the damn thinks that he carries
a gun dude and I was like you just want
something to think that he [ __ ]
carrying they just wants us to think
that he thinks he's carrying his gun
because he thinks it's Robert De Niro in
[ __ ] Goodfellas and he would eat so
much because he was trying to gain
muscle he just want to be the biggest he
could possibly be and we used to make
fun of him so badly like he would eat so
much but he would have to [ __ ] Vaughn
like he always got two meals always he'd
be like you know what let me get a
burger and then also let me get the
breakfast and we beat a diner at [ __ ]
Gramercy Park and he would just be
eating the [ __ ] and he'd be like I'll be
like man you're gonna you look bad dude
you're gonna look throw up he's like no
I need it cuz I'm buddy I'm trying to
beef up and he walk dude and he had a
poo pick in his mouth all the time and
he had like [ __ ] shoulders that
sloped down he look like a turtle you
know I mean and he [ __ ] walked so me
so don't like this you know how like
guys walk like this sometimes cuz they
think they're bad ass god I love that
[ __ ] man we would bust on him so
much he came to visit in in in in LA
when we were on spring break when
wouldn't Ted throw up out the side
because of mind erasers and my family my
dad got a [ __ ] slam man remember
those slam man's that would have no arms
and you just beat the [ __ ] out of him
he'd box him they were just like they
came out and like I don't know maybe
1995 and you and and you would just box
some sparring Bob you know those kinds
of things and we had one of the
slam did that was the one we had the
slam man that won the the yeah the down
no right nope the blue one yeah that
would I dare ya slam it and and and
nobody ever use it one of those things
that you you know you get and then you'd
never use ever you just feel like oh
cool I [ __ ] started boxing the
slamming and it just stays in the garage
next to your car and Dan was like oh you
gotta focus slam in and and we would
make fun of us or they would come home
late at night every time we came home
from spring break hanging out and he
would just be like we'd be like where's
Dan dude and then we would go down in
the garage and turn the light on and he
would be [ __ ] hittin the slam man just
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] well what'd
we [ __ ] looks at me dude and we would
laugh so hard do it with his toothpick
in his mouth
just [ __ ] rocking the slam man killing
it just boxing uh yeah man
[ __ ] dude and then he literally [ __ ]
did and he went out on a motorcycle
which was like it's so darkly funny it
was like he was probably trying to do a
[ __ ] wheelie with a toothpick in his
mouth I love that kid dude I [ __ ]
miss him and so I'm gonna go see our
other buddy Ted and Tom was the guy who
he is Irish as [ __ ] - I haven't seen him
in a bit I should hit him up next time I
go to New York they all live in New York
there's such business guys you know I
think Ted moved to [ __ ] Poland and
then moved by that's how business you
moved to [ __ ] Poland dude you go to
NYU and then move to Poland s business
school dude [ __ ] s a business school to
go from NYU to Poland and then make
millions and then move to Venice a
business school you know alright